this is a superhero story about somebody
who the more they kind of get in touch
with their humanity and the more that
they accept their own humanity the more
powerful she becomes the creature Omar
is a big part of the backdrop for this
movie it's something that Captain Marvel
is caught up in and ends up on earth and
earth gets in the middle of it
the scrawls are really really fun part
of the comic book history to bring it to
life in the cinematic universe they've
never been scrolls before and what could
be more fun than telling a story about
aliens and characters who could look
literally like anybody we meet Nick Fury
and Phil Coulson and a blockbuster in
this movie which is kind of exciting but
where are they at I mean Nick Fury
doesn't know that superheroes exist he
doesn't know that aliens exist he learns
a whole lot in this movie he's kind of
he's a guy who's thinks he's seen it all
coming into this movie and then realizes
some way he's not seen at all in his
mind is about to get blown breeze
incredible yes she's the best she's a
superhero on camera and off it is insane
how dynamic the character that she plays
in this movie is and how much she brings
to it she got so invested in just the
physical aspect of this movie and she
learned to fight she trained for months
and and the she does so many of her own
stunts in this movie it's completely
insane because it's not something she's
ever done before so there's that aspect
of it and then there's the emotional
aspect of it which is obviously she can
bring so much humanity to it and
ultimately this is a superhero story
about somebody who the the more they
kind of get in touch with their own
humanity and the more that they accept
their own humanity the more powerful she
becomes and so she was just
absolutely the right person for this go
see Marvel Studios Captain Marvel in
theaters now